this fresh scrutiny for police in the
valley texas as a 9-1-1 dispatch call
appears to confirm officers were told
the gunman was in a room full of victims
as they stood outside
[Music]
well lydia morales along with her mother
monica cared for many of the victims of
their daycare center when they were just
toddlers then they set up a memorial 21
chairs with each of the names of each of
the children and the two teachers who
were killed on a white piece of paper
and lydia joins me now lydia thank you
so much for joining me i really
appreciate it i can't even imagine what
it must be like for all of you connected
with this school and these poor children
who were murdered
you had
i think over 10 of these kids come
through
your daycare center when you first heard
what had happened what were your
feelings
um
i was really in shock
i didn't think
this could happen especially to a small
community
when we actually heard what was going on
um
we
locked down our daycare center just to
ensure the safety just because there was
a lot of commotion going on especially
because our daycare is actually located
by
if i'm not mistaken it's dalton
elementary so
there was just a lot of questions going
on at that time
and so you know just for safety protocol
we locked down our daycare center and
hoping that
we kept the safety for everybody it must
have been agonizing for you to discover
that so many of the
children who've been at your day care
center had actually been killed
yes it was
and i also know that it's hard to think
that these families are not going to be
able to hold these
that they're not going to be able to
hold their
child ever again
yeah i mean it's an incomprehensible
atrocity it's not a tragedy because a
tragedy implies somehow this you know
this this
was accidental or something this is a
deliberate annihilation of young
children
by an 18 year old who
just decided to destroy their lives i
know that you're also personally close
to mrs garcia one of the two
teachers who died she actually taught
you
so this is very personal for you isn't
it
yes it is she actually did she was um
she was my third grade teacher here at
the school right behind me rob
elementary
i was here
probably when i was like 10 as well so a
good 12 years ago
i walked the same hall that
the
tragedy took place
lydia what is your what is your feeling
there's a huge debate raging now about
guns about mental health
about all sorts of issues which may have
contributed to this
what is the feeling do you think of the
community about what's happened here
i think a lot
of it needs to change at least with the
gun violence they need to change and
mental health needs to be taken
seriously and not just as
a walk-in talk thing it needs to be
where you need to sit down with that
person talk about what's going on with
them talk about their
past history
especially even now more so with the
tragedy that took place here
i mean there's always been a debate
after all of these massacres in america
about gun control
you know taking some guns away from
certain types of people it does seem
strange
to us here in the uk for example that an
18 year old can't buy a beer
until they're 21
that they can buy a semi-automatic rifle
do you think that
something like that or to change that
kids young people teenagers should not
be able to get these kind of guns
i do believe something does need a
change because
like you were saying how your laws are
different from here from the united
states it
i mean here they i mean they could buy a
beer at 21 but they could buy legal guns
and stuff at 18 years old it just
doesn't seem right
especially even now more so that
this tragedy took place
that involved
you know guns
uh taking the life of 21 people
you've done this wonderful little
tribute of these chairs what was it that
made you want to do that in particular
we just wanted to show our support for
the community especially during this
tragic time especially for the families
um
i noticed right now too we have more
people putting out bears they're putting
flowers they're putting the little rocks
that have messages and stuff in hopes
that um
with all this stuff we will be able to
give it to their families as a you know
as a reminder that we're all here
together in new valley we're standing
strong for one another
lydia is there anger amongst the local
community about the way the police
conducted themselves there's a big
debate now that there were 19 police
with guns
in the school and they didn't go in for
over an hour
okay
can you repeat that
i just wondered what what your view is
of the debate about the
failure of the police to go in go into
the classroom given they were in in the
school for over an hour
i do believe there is some anger around
the community
but at the same time
you know everybody's trying to hold
together at least to be strong for the
families of these
lives that were taken
yeah i completely understand lydia thank
you so much for joining me it's it's
just
unbearable to think what has happened
there and the fact that you knew
10 of these children who'd come through
your day center the fact you used to be
taught by one of the teachers who died
it must be particularly unbearable for
you and i'm incredibly grateful to you
for taking the time to talk to us
tonight
okay thank you
beyond comprehension but i'm joined now
by chris grollneck he's a retired police
officer an active shooter prevention
expert and fox nation host tommy lehrer
welcome to both of you um let me start
with you chris if i may you're a
specialist
in this very kind of scenario you know i
wrote a column for the new york post
yesterday and just really just
lambasting what happened here as
i'm afraid cowardice i mean the idea
that 19
armed police were in that
school
for over an hour and didn't go into that
classroom is to me unconscionable
yeah thank you for having me pearson
hello tommy great to see you again um
for this tragedy i wish we weren't
speaking about this however what we've
seen is we've spent about 10 million
dollars since sandy hook on training
approximately 140 000 police on response
tactics of how to respond to an active
shooter and we see
after a similar pulse
parkland yuvaldi and there's several
others
they're not responding appropriately and
there's no excuse for this one and i
haven't you know much speaking out of a
side of my mouth i've been in an active
shooter in real time as a policeman
where somebody just decides they're
going to start shooting at you um and
they attack you and you have no uh call
so you have to react
um this is different domestic soil these
are children and i don't really speak
about children but there's a message to
be evangelized here and that is we have
to change
a lot not just a binary choice of guns
or mental health we have to evaluate the
whole spectrum and decide who we're
talking to
right i mean i think tommy you know you
and i have talked about guns before i
want to re-legislate that debate what
strikes me about this particular
two-week period you've had the mass
shooting in buffalo where 10 black
people were murdered by a white
supremacist in a supermarket you've now
had 19 children
annihilated in their classroom exactly
the same as what happened in sandy hook
10 years ago and we know nothing got
changed and it's not as simple as saying
take all the guns away there are too
many guns in america to do that and also
there is a constitutional right which i
know a lot of americans feel strongly
about about their right to bear arms and
we just don't have that kind of issue
here so i'm not going to legislate that
with you i'm just curious
what what can be done here there were
the normal response from the pro-gun
lobby is well you need to have more guns
so that good guys with guns can stop it
but we had 19 supposedly good guys with
guns in the school hallway doing nothing
so that can't be the answer
well i think that we have to look at
this situation apart from other
situations where law enforcement did
fail here and i am a big advocate and
supporter of law enforcement but we have
to take a look at the situation there's
going to be an investigation and the
people of that community and the people
of the world deserve to know what
happened what lapsing communication
occurred there and what went so wrong
back to the discussion and about guns
what we do to address this issue it is a
an issue of mental health as well and
i'll speak to that in a moment but i
would also say this when we're talking
about our constitutional rights making
law abiding citizens helpless and
outgunned does not make evil people any
less harmful so that is a discussion
that needs to be had but also mental
health when you look at individuals like
this there is a common thread in pattern
these individuals are on social media
platforms and different chat rooms
torturing animals abusing animals
talking about violence talking about how
they want to harm people why is there
not a mechanism to report this the world
is watching these individuals promised
to do harm and nothing is done i mean i
agree with you
as i would also say
yeah i would say look i agree there are
a number of things at play here mental
health is clearly a massive problem
these are evil twisted people and they
all seem to be getting younger and
younger
and it's incredibly worrying i know that
the sandy hook shooter for example and
this shooter both had a weird obsession
with call of duty which is a video game
where you play a lone shooter right is
there no connection between that and
mental illness and the ready
availability of guns i'm sure there is a
connection there are lots of things
going on here but i think the rest of
the world looks at these incidents in
america happening a time and time again
and just wonders
whether anything will actually be done
about guns themselves and what do you
think the answer is i mean when i asked
that when i asked the the lady earlier
you know this guy couldn't buy a beer
till he was 21 americans accept that
they accept that they accept regulation
when they drive cars which can be
dangerous um but
why was he able to get a semi-automatic
rifle
i just interject on one thing pierce
because i i do think it's a simple
question as well okay chris yeah
i i apologize so we know that 100 of
active shooters and mass killers share a
common trait out of a number of common
traits the problem with that benchmark
is
me and you share at least one of those
traits maybe we've been wronged in our
whole life maybe we had whatever the
problem is so if we throw that metric
out and we look at one statistic that
the fbi has put out in 21 years
47.3 percent of active shooters
telegraph that they're going to be
active shooters and yet they still
legally purchase firearms right that's
where i tell you i am i am aggressive i
think the lack of i think it's like a
jump increase i think the lack of the
lack of proper red flag spotting you
know every single time stuff comes out
about these shooters you think well why
didn't that get picked up why wasn't
that rather shown on their background
check when they go and get these guns
legally but tommy you wanted to to
answer before chris stepped in there yes
when i agree with chris wholeheartedly
we also need to address some of the
cultural issues that we have in the
united states of america and it's not
just gun culture it's also a culture of
fatherlessness it's a culture of young
people falling through the cracks and
i'm glad that chris is talking about
some of these traits because you don't
see young women doing this you see young
men doing this young men who are
incredibly angry young men who often
share that common thread of not having
fathers or parents in the household that
are raising them correctly so we're
going to have to address a whole litany
of issues it's not just the gun i know
it's easy to go after the weapon but
there are millions of americans who own
firearms and who own what they call
assault weapons and they don't go out
and they don't become mass shooters they
use them for home defense and protection
so there's bigger issues to be discussed
here besides just the weapon important
issues that are a little bit more
challenging and that's why i feel that
so many fail to address that i think it
is a very complex issue in america you
know when britain got rid of its guns
after the dunblane massacre in the 90s
we were not a gun culture country most
people in britain did not have a gun to
start with so it's a much easier thing
to do and a much easier thing for all
sides of the political divide to agree
with so it's a it's very complicated in
america i completely accept that listen
leave it there chris tommy thank you
both very much indeed for joining us
thank you both
thank you